هو احتكار Google ، فلنتحدث عن
سبب اعتقاد بعض الناس أنه كذلك ،
وعندما تتحدث عن الاحتكارات ، فإن أول
شيء تريد القيام به هو تحديد ماهية
السوق ،
فلنبدأ نشاطها الإعلاني ،
تتحكم Google حاليًا في 37٪ من جميع مبيعات الإعلانات الرقمية
في  الولايات المتحدة وهذا ما يقرب من ضعف
أكبر شركة تالية وهي
Facebook ، وهذا رقم ضخم لما
هو أعلى قطاع فردي متنام في
جميع الإعلانات ، لذلك إذا نظرت إلى
سوق عائدات الإعلانات عبر الإنترنت ، فإن Google هي
المهيمنة ولكن إذا سألت Google عن ذلك "
سأخبرك أنه لا يوجد سوق ليس
عائدات إعلانات رقمية ، إنه في الواقع جميع الإعلانات ،
إنه تلفزيون ،
إنه يطبع لوحاته الإعلانية ، لذا تتحكم Google في
37 ٪ من سوق الإعلانات الرقمية
في الولايات المتحدة ، ولكن إذا قمت بتوسيعها
لتشمل السوق الأوسع لجميع الإعلانات
في الولايات المتحدة ، تبلغ النسبة 14٪ فقط ولكن هذا
لا يزال أكثر من صناعة الطباعة بأكملها
وكل عام تأخذ الإعلانات الرقمية
شريحة أكبر وأكبر من
الكعكة الإجمالية ، ولا نقارن Google
بشركات فردية هنا.  قم
بتوصيله إلى صناعات كاملة ، وهذا هو مدى
ضخامة Google وهذا الحجم هو بالضبط
ما يشير إليه نقاد مكافحة الاحتكار
عندما يقولون إن Google أكبر من اللازم
، كما يقولون إن Google تسلط الضوء على
منتجاتها ونتائج البحث الخاصة بها
على منتجات الشركات الأخرى العقارية
تعد صفحة بحث Google من
أكثر الصفحات قيمة في جميع مواقع الإنترنت وعلى
مدار السنوات القليلة الماضية ، أضافت
Google المزيد والمزيد من منتجات Google إليها هنا
، فلنأخذ مثالاً ، دعونا
نكتب المرتبة حرفيًا الشاشة بأكملها
إما إعلانات Google أو  صفحة Google Shopping
الآن تقول Google إنها تفعل ذلك
لأن هذا يساعد الأشخاص في العثور على
المعلومات بشكل أسرع وأن
منتجاتها أفضل من منافسيها
ولكن يقول آخرون إنها تجعل المنافسة
مع Google مستحيلة وأن
منتجات Google التي تصادف Google
تسليط الضوء عليها هي أيضًا تجعل
Google  بمليارات الدولارات من العائدات
تساعد المستخدمين ولكن أيضًا تساعد Google في
رؤية نفس التأثير الديناميكي
مع Chrome لأن  يعد Chrome إلى حد بعيد
أكبر متصفح Safari Internet Explorer ،
فايرفوكس كلها تشكل مجتمعة حوالي 20٪
من سوق المتصفحات ، يمتلك Chrome وحده
ثلاثة أضعاف هذا العدد ، كما أن التحكم في
كيفية وصول غالبية الأشخاص إلى
الإنترنت يمنح
Google القوة للقيام بأشياء مثل
التبديل.  وتشغيل حظر الإعلانات الآن ،
تقول Google إنهم فعلوا هذا لأن
هذا شيء يريده المستخدمون
ويحميهم ، لكن adblock من Google
لا يقوم بتصفية جميع الإعلانات الضارة فقط
وإعلانات Google لا تزال
مقبولة ، لذا وضعت Google adblock على
Chrome لأن  إنها تساعد عملائها أو
لأنها تساعد أعمالها الإعلانية في الظهور
بأشخاص مثل Google والمنتجات التي
يصنعونها والعديد من تحركات Google
تسهل على الأشخاص الحصول على
المعلومات بسرعة وبشكل واضح ولكن هذا
هو الموقف الصعب الذي
يجد منظمو مكافحة الاحتكار أنفسهم فيه  في الإجراءات
التي قد تساعد المستخدمين من بعض النواحي ، يمكن
أن تشكل أيضًا تهديدًا للمنافسة العادلة ، ولكن
هذا هو السؤال الذي يجعل
Google مهيمنة جدًا.  هناك
أي غرفة لـ Google التالية هي
Google أكبر من اللازم